hello in this video i explain
how you can calculate the effect strength of a
square with the
ksv and let's start with that
what is normal the square means the
square test is a hypothesis test
that is used when you
want to determine whether it  there is a
connection between two categorical
variables the categorical variables are, for example,
gender with the characteristics
male female the preferred
newspaper bild faz and handelsblatt the
frequency of television or the
highest educational qualification all of these are
categorical variables non-
categorical variables are for
example weight and salary
of a person so whenever you have two
categorical variables that you
want to check is whether there is
a connection you use the
squares
so we now come to the question of what is
the field strength the effect strength
basically indicates how strong an
observed effect is depending on
which one  hypotheses  e you test is effect
for example for difference or connection
how big is the
difference how strong is the connection
let's say you asked 40 women
and 40 men whether they have
studied or not and you now want to
find out whether gender has a
strong influence on it  whether one
studies or not 12 of the 40
women answered they have studied and
ten of the 40 men
answered they have studied if you
look at these numbers
now without examining them too closely
you would probably say that
the gender is not a big one  has an influence
on whether you have studied or whether
you have not studied, however,
let's look at this example here
again 40 women and 40 men were interviewed
in this case 18 of the women
said they studied and I think
five of the men said they did  have
studied accordingly in this
case the sex has a much
larger  er influence on whether you have
studied or not
so in this example we have a
smaller effect stronger than in this
example
but what is the difference to the p
value the ph value you use and
either keep or reject your 0 hypothesis so you have
your 0 made
an alternative hypothesis
and now you use a statistical
software like data to calculate the value
if this value is now smaller
than the previously defined significant
level the new hypothesis is rejected
if it is larger it will be retained you have now checked whether it is
based on  from the available data in
the population there is a
connection or it is not important but that
the p will not tell you anything about the strength
of the connection or the
effect and the p value depends
very much on the sample size
what does that mean now there is in the
population a connection is
this mp is displayed more clearly
depending  if the sample is larger, if the
sample is very large, very small connections can also
be detected in the total population,
so if we have a small
sample and a large
sample and in both
samples the gender has the
same influence on whether one has
studied or  Wouldn't the ph value
still differ
?  strength to
use again the p value says nothing
about the strength of the connection house
but only whether the connection is
significant or not
what does the rfec strength say when the square
is off when the square remainder is checked
whether the occurring frequencies are
independent
of this difference over several
studies  note  to make g comparable
, the rfec strength is needed
let's look at our
previous example again, where we interviewed 40 women and 40
men, say we did
the same study again, only
with ten times as many participants,
i.e. with 400 women and four men in
this one  In this case, however, we have a
much larger sample,
so on average we should get
a much
smaller p value in this example than in
this example simply because
we interviewed many more people and
therefore the connection
becomes significant more quickly around these two
studies anyway  to make a comparison
the field strength is needed the effect
strength at
square can be calculated using
the ksv the ksv is found using this equation
where the sample size is the
number of columns in the cross table
and he is the number of rows in the
cross chapel and square is natural
the calculated square for the
interpreta  tion of the effect strength,
this table can be
used, a value of 0.1 is considered small, a
value of 0.3 is medium and a value of
0 5 is large and now i will show
you how you can easily calculate the ksv online
To do this, please go to
day.de and click on the statistics
calculator
. You can now copy your own data into this table. To do
this, please
click on the table of teachers.
I have prepared a small example here.
We can now
simply copy it into datatec.
In this example, you simply have
counted in bad weather how many
male and how many female
people come into the lecture hall with an umbrella
so on the one hand you have
the variable gender and on the
other hand you have the variable whether
they come into the lecture hall with an umbrella
or not we  so want to
know if gender has an influence
on using
an umbrella in bad weather or
not  please make sure that the
variable name is in the first row
now these two variables appear
below we want to calculate a tea
square so let's look at
the square now let's just select
gender and screen
now we get the results
for the  ki square fixed
we see the observed frequencies
we see the expected frequencies
and we see here whether the result is
significant or not
we want to know the effect strength
so we simply click on the
effect strength button for the square that can
that came as well as for  the calculation of the
field strength can be used
in this case we have a kbv of 0
08 3 so we only have a small
effect therefore gender has only
a small effect on whether you use an
umbrella or not of
course you can
summarize the overall result in words
just click on this button
if you want to know more about the  quadrates
knowledge just look at the video on
the left
if you want to know how you can easily do
many more analyzes online with the app
look at
the video on the right chips
and see you next time